- [Instructor] What we're going
to try to do in this video
is find the area of this figure.
And we can see it's a quadrilateral.
It has 1, 2, 3, 4 sides.
And we know that this side and this side
that they're parallel to each other.
You can see that they
both form right angles
with this dotted line.
So pause this video and see
if you can find the area.
All right.
Now, if you had a little
bit of trouble with that
I'll give you a hint.
What if we were to take this quadrilateral
and divide it into two triangles?
So let me do this in a color
that you are likely to see.
So if I were to draw a line like this
it now divides the quadrilateral
into two triangles.
If I were to take this
triangle right over here
I could take it out and reorient it,
so it looks something like this,
where the base has length 8,
and then the height right
over here, the height
this has length 5.
So that would be that triangle.
And then, this triangle over here
if you were to take it out
and reorient it a little bit
it could look like this,
where the base is 4,
and the triangle looks something like,
looks something like this.
So the base is 4,
and then the height is going to be 5.
So this height right
over here, this height,
we notice this is a right angle.
So from here to here,
which is the same thing
as from here to right over here,
we know that this is 5.
So that's my fairly big hint to you,
if you know how to find
the area of a triangle.
The area of a triangle we
know is 1/2 base times height.
So the area of this one right over here
is gonna be 1/2 times 8 times 5.
And the area of this one over here
is going to be 1/2 times the base,
which is 4 times the height, which is 5.
And we could evaluate each of these,
or we could just add them together.
That the area of the entire thing
is going to be 1/2 times
this base right over here
which is 8, times the height, which is 5,
plus 1/2 times this side,
you could do that as
the other base, times 4
times that same height, times 5.
And obviously, you
could just evaluate this
or we could see some
interesting things about it.
We could express this as well
if we were to factor
out 1/2 and the 5 here.
This could be rewritten as 1/2,
1/2 times 8 plus 4,
8 plus 4.
And then, all of that, all of
that times 5 right over here.
And so, another way you
could think about it is
the average of the length
of these two bases.
You could view this as base 1 and base 2,
you multiply that times the height
and you have the area
of this quadrilateral.
Well, what's that going to be?
8 plus 4 is 12.
1/2 times 12, this is all going to be 6.
6 times 5 is going to be
equal to 30 square units.
You could have figured it out here too.
1/2 times 8 is 4, times 5 is 20.
And then, this would've
been 1/2 times 4 is 2,
times 5 is 10.
20 plus 10 is 30 square units once again.